[Music]
welcome everybody wherever you are to
this event sponsored by the corporation
society initiative cassie at stanford
gsb
my name is anathed mati and i'm a
faculty director
of cassie
with cassisic to engage
the broader community here and elsewhere
on issues around governance
in business and in government which are
essential for our market system to
deliver on its promise
we want powerful people and institutions
to be accountable to society
i'm a professor of finance and today is
about finance and financial markets
what does that have to do with cassie
in our basic finance courses which i've
taught for many years we assert that the
stock price embodies all the great
things corporations can do
all the positive net present value
projects
our basic teachings and the models that
most academics study assume away the
possibility
of fraud
and do not have hedge fund investors who
try to make money
finding fraud and betting on price going
down
uh when they do find it but today we
have that counter example right here
we're so lucky to be able to host
famicadeer who will explain in further
detail why her work is so relevant for
cassie
and moderating this event and
introducing her further is one of our
amazing
student leaders chris kobamb who
actually is himself from the financial
sector and going back
to the financial sector so i'm sure it'd
be a fascinating discussion and thank
you all to our leaders anna the ramon is
watching the uh chat uh the q a
for for your questions
and um thanks loretta and the event team
at gsb for making this event possible
i let chris take it over from here thank
you very much
i thank thank you a knot and good
afternoon to everybody joining us here
virtually today
glad to have you all here with us for
this very special session
by way by way of introduction i am a
second year mba student here at the
stanford graduate school of business and
as i not mentioned i myself come from
the finance and investing world with uh
four years at j.p morgan before the
business school and joining blackrock as
an investment professional on upon
graduation
um so without further further ado i am
honored to introduce uh family kadeer
our guest of honor
um fami is the founder of the hedge fund
soft capital where she focuses on
concentrated short positions driven by
in-depth investigation of fraud and
corporate crimes
for those in the room who may not be
familiar with the term short selling is
when an investor like fami borrow shares
of stock to sell today with the
expectation that the stock price will
fall and they will be able to buy those
shares back at a lower feature price
they're probably pocketing the
difference
the potential losses are theoretically
infinite as there's no limit to how high
a stock price can go
and in a bull market like we've had the
past
as we've had the past decade stocks
mostly tend to go up
so fami is here with us today to shed a
light on how she has persevered through
such an environment and our work keeps
companies accountable at the end of the
day
so family we'd love to start off by
getting your take on the state of play
today you know with rising inflation
increasing shocks to the market
geopolitical tension do you think we're
in a materially different spot from last
year what does that mean
so
thank you chris and thank you or not um
and thank you to the stanford community
and to cassie
for hosting me virtually this year um
i'm joining you all from london
the latest place that my work has taken
me um so so it's evening here
and i'm hopeful that maybe next semester
i'll be able to join you guys on campus
um
so to start i think there's little
that's more insufferable than hearing
single stock fundamental investors talk
economics so
i'll do i'll do my best to stay in my
lane here
um for as long as i've been in the
business i've heard
managers very publicly very boisterously
complain about the fed about negative
interest rates about quantitative easing
and they've always blamed all of this
for their underperformance
at the same time they've allowed this
myth of the fed put to become totally
internalized it's a part of the
collective investment consciousness
right now and this fed put has been used
to justify complete speculation um i
think most normal people would call it
gambling
um these are behaviors that a few years
ago at least from my seat were things
that would be dismissed as day trading
but it's now become accepted investing
practice and we are seeing it especially
in liquid markets like crypto and like
within equities
so this kind of gambling mentality has
almost become muscle memory for
investors who once upon a time may have
considered themselves fundamental
investors so it's going to take a lot
a lot for these investors to unlearn
some of these bad behaviors
um so even if the economic reality is
that you're talking about
wages prices ukraine
even though we're constantly exposed to
these narratives it's not really sinking
in
rather it's sometimes what we see is
that the market is often driven by false
narratives and one thing that i started
hearing a lot um starting at the end of
last year was that value is king and
that growth is dead
okay
i i can understand why
why people might say this at first
because of course we did see a sell-off
in the qqq so the top 100 names in the
nasdaq so we saw a lot of the repricing
and some of these growth momentum driven
names but at the same time you know what
does value really mean
um i believe that markets are generally
pretty efficient so if something a
company has been trading at a very you
know like a single digit multiple
for many years
i don't know if i would necessarily call
that cheap it's probably garbage
so the thing is that we saw during the
pandemic were you know a lot of
businesses
that were on their last leg that were
reaching for
fraud for example to
extend
their their life cycle
um suddenly had
extra liquidity that was completely
unexpected um and over that period they
were able to buy additional time they
would buy additional time to you know
continue to defraud people for example
so we saw a lot of you know these
consumer finance businesses for example
we like to look at payday lenders
all of them got you know a new lease on
life um because of all this liquidity
but the thing is these things were
always trading below book value they
were always trading as cheap businesses
on if you look at you know multiples
why is that it's because
these businesses are a dependent on
screwing over their customer um so over
time the business model blows up
especially when you're you know entering
a tightening cycle um as far as credit
so this is one of the false narratives
that i've seen
um
pop up in the past few months where
where people
are considering only that a business is
generating cash but not the quality of
that cash flow which should be equally
as important
uh but another thing
that i'm hearing a lot uh is that oh you
know so and so stock is now down 50
so the bottom is in buy the dip
so what that tells me is that even
though the headlines are showing that
we're all a lot more uncertain about
what the future looks like uh
people are still using share price as
the ultimate determination you know a
determining factor for their various
investment decisions their call on
whether a business is going to grow or
fail it's it's again still driven by
price driven by momentum
so while
some investors are starting to you know
get their mojo back thinking that maybe
we're getting back to fundamentals as
someone who's sort of been watching this
play out and is hyper exposed to
prices that are disconnected from
fundamentals i'd like to say that you
know as much as i'd like to say that
we're getting there i just i don't know
if we have we're not there yet again
we're trying to you know use this false
fundamental sprinkling of a narrative
on top of something that still hasn't
changed which is
you know
price is being driven by these
narratives
and and sometimes these false narratives
is driven by sentiment and and momentum
um not by real analysis
um
so it's it's a it's a very
while it seems hopeful and you know if
you just look at how the portfolio has
performed over the last six months
compared to you know the past
year
um obviously things seem like they've
gotten better but it's never really
satisfying when things are moving
for reasons other than
you know the various pieces of
information we've picked out in our
analysis so it's interesting for me that
you mentioned this huge focus on
narrative over analysis kind of taking
prevalence and determining how people
are deciding what to invest in in the
market today i think if you look back to
last year there's maybe no narrative
that got more pressed than the gamestop
saga so i think one question that's on
our audience minds is what is your
understanding of what happened there i i
don't know i i get asked about this a
lot
um but i i
i think
at base
while the media is trying to create like
a david goliath story
or you know talking about hedge funds
taking on excessive leverage you know
taking on these these you know
ridiculous bets
that stuff has always existed retail
investors have also always existed
they've just become they become more
prevalent and they become um you know
they're more part of the the
our focus as a society
in the peak of the bull market right
because that's when people start seeing
advertisements for crypto
during you know while they're watching
the super bowl and then you know just
you know grandma might be watching the
super bowl and saying you know i'm not
making any money holding my cash in the
bank you know why don't i get into those
high yields crypto savings accounts
so
we're at that point in the cycle where
you kind of had this this strange
tension
where
clearly things
are maybe
going to not be as good as they've been
right we clearly had the pandemic and
that has covered up a lot
of you know bad behavior in some of the
businesses that we look like it provided
liquidity to businesses that probably
shouldn't have had it
um
but now we're we're going to see like
what what is the consequence of all of
that um you know have we seen
peak growth at least in the near term
and what does that mean for businesses
that were simply not growing or were
simply losing money for the past decades
um
so
as much as
it feels as though certain stocks have
had these violent moves um you know in
in reality
i would say most people are as bullish
as ever and and there's some there's
like a danger to this because it's it's
this mentality that
the this idea that the stock market
can never
go down
or 80 percent because
it would be it's almost like an
apocalyptic sort of situation people
can't fathom the idea that prices may
correct and multiples may change and the
way the economy has been growing it it
might slow down it's there's almost it's
like we've been trying to delude
ourselves into thinking nothing you know
this time is different but it's rarely
ever different including these
situations like gamestop and amc and the
rise of the retail trader it always
happens um it's it's really just you
know everyone is going to try to enjoy
the party while it lasts um but who's
going to be the last one to leave
so i i suppose with with that that focus
then on sort of
narrative and the rational factors
taking a back seat
that tends to drown out sort of the
strength of a well-reasoned investment
thesis and i'm wondering then does that
change how you think about the role that
you play in the market
it is it's really really difficult i
can't understate how difficult it is
um the the the guys that i
i went to for advice
that i looked up to when i was starting
soft cat and figuring out you know how
do i get a short only fund
um
you know up and running those guys are
retiring
you know and not because they're old but
simply because it's it's so it's
intolerable the the losses that short
sellers have had to suffer have been
intolerable
um
but it's not just that
it's it's sort of this cycle where yes
the losses are bad because the markets
are going up because there's a lot of
liquidity and because fundamentals
have become much more disconnected from
price but it's also you know that also
feeds into the capital allocation cycle
where allocators are looking at short
sellers and saying you know why am i
going to pay to be hedged in this market
i'll just lose money so
there hasn't been much you know
allocating activity to short focused
funds so that is also has pushed us to
the the brink of extinction
um
and it's just you can only tolerate so
so much
right as far as far as losses as far as
willing to to tolerate those losses in
the market so many short sellers have
just tried to figure out different ways
of doing things um and you know
everyone's heard
the the phrase you know a bull market
dies when the last bear capitulates
um so i would think i think the
statement's a little bit archaic
um because maybe in prior market cycles
there were no bears like me who who have
the the pain tolerance to continue doing
this because throughout this entire
period we've remained short only and
we've always remained you know exposed
to that risk in the market
um and yeah it's it's it's certainly not
easy i understand why people don't want
to do it
but
you know when the clearing moment
happens in the market
whenever that is whatever that looks
like it's people like me that come to
pick up the pieces
um because we've already done the work
we understand these businesses so we can
help provide signals for you know what's
the most effective and the safest ways
to allocate capital in that new
market order um whenever it comes
so perhaps let let's maybe shift gears a
little bit because i think there's
another topic that also tends to come up
a lot here at stanford and that's the
increasing importance of private markets
as a conduit of capital to the growing
companies of today so you now have this
growing space where you don't have the
ability to maybe easily bet against
these companies
how do you how do you hold them
accountable if most of the capital being
raised is now in a space where
it's not easy to put on a position
against them
so i'm glad i'm not there in person for
this question because i think i would
have had some tomatoes thrown at me
um but you know i just like to ask you
do private investors need protecting
um because i would say in most cases
public markets need to be protected from
private investor exits
um these private equity nbc dudes
they're not stupid they are stupid rich
so in most cases in my experience
these investors know exactly
whether the technology or idea they're
investing in is something that's even
remotely plausible
more often than not they just don't care
they'll happily invest in these
non-ideas that are completely
fantastical
because well let's see
they get in these businesses at
ridiculous terms
um their investors
give them more money to do it and
they'll pay them higher fees
so if you want to keep
getting more stupid rich you need to
invest in more and you know stupider and
stupider businesses
because as long as the equity markets
are preaching you buy the dip look at
that tam
diamond hands then private equity
investors will get their exit
so
what we've seen over the past decade is
that hedge fund managers are looking at
all this and saying hey
we can't make money in public markets
anymore so we're going to do that too
and it's just been toxic
it's toxic for public markets because
the pension funds the retail investors
who get duped into buying this trash
they're the ones who are holding the bag
but it's also toxic for the businesses
themselves um i think a very good
example of some you know the toxic
elements of this
is you know what you see happening
in tel aviv uh it's become now it's the
most expensive city in the world
softbank has opened an office there
you have millions that are being thrown
at very smart young people
who don't have any idea what they're
going to build or what they're going to
do with that money
and if you you know just ignoring the
businesses that might have come public
um
that might be you know sort of fraudy
there are startups that are good ideas
that are run by good people
that deserve a chance at growing their
business that are being prematurely
forced to go public
through spacks because
and oftentimes at absurd absurd
valuations that the founders never ever
would have imagined
and would never accept except their vc
backers are egging them on to do it
um so they're now entering public
markets when they're totally not
prepared for it uh so so to me this is
literally value destruction
it is not innovation um it's like the
opposite side of vulture capitalism
but it's it's equally damaging
so you know how do we solve this problem
again it comes down to allocators
allocators continuously
pump money into private equity funds
into venture capital they should they
they hold you know they hold the bag so
they should do more to hold these
various firms accountable and that's i
think the place to start
so i guess maybe what what follows from
that then is
you know as i guess as a gp who's had
conversations with allocators
what question do you think they ought to
be asking that they aren't that would
help them maybe figure out who's for
real and who's just chasing the latest
trend
well they really should be thinking
about what is the real thesis
behind this investment
you know is
is my manager
providing some kind of story
that isn't even
a solid story that they're using to you
know just as like a veneer to cover up
what they know is a
guaranteed money-making
venture
the thing is with these sorts of like
situations
regulators are watching politicians are
watching
increasingly private equity venture
capital is no longer the darling you
know driving innovation driving silicon
valley people are starting to call out
the fees call out the way that they
actually measure their performance um
they're calling out the effect that
they're having on these new developing
businesses so
you know before something
you know before someone's hand is forced
you know allocators should really be
more thoughtful and put more pressure on
having these
these firms actually explain
what the business is what is the plan
for that business
and
what you know is a realistic exit so
that those businesses will not just
collapse after the venture backing has
been pulled
and so i think kind of branching off of
that there's maybe there's the allocator
angle to look at and then perhaps the
regulator angle as well
and i think one question that's been
raised a little bit now is how the
recent sec focus on on spack accounting
and restatements is going to impact some
of that behavior and sort of what's your
take on that
i think you know
it should have happened sooner
it should have happened sooner because
think about how many specs came to
market before the sec came out and said
that we need to take a look at the
disclosure requirements for these facts
um we are we're always slow
you know to the ball fraudsters are
always
wait wait you know fraudsters and greedy
people are always going to be many steps
ahead of us
um so i would think
that given the scrutiny that the sec is
now um
focusing upon stacks
um and just the risks involved and and
the fact that spax are wildly
underperforming the market right now i
think businesses business founders will
give you know some more thought to just
going along with what their vc partners
are saying
um and and they'll probably hold off
on trying to come to market through us
back and we are actually seeing this
happen more where you know these these
mergers just sort of blow up
um so so that's a good thing uh but the
companies that are still pursuing the
stacks are you know at this point in the
in the cycle i think are guaranteed to
be garbage for for the most part that's
at least from what i've seen
and i think that's a sentiment that's
being echoed in a lot of places where
the flow of spat capital is all but
dried up in more recent months um so i
think maybe we can shift gears a little
bit maybe talk about some of the ins and
outs of what you do as a short seller
i think one of the biggest uh i think
one of the biggest challenges that we
hear about from the outside is that a
lot of the executive teams management
teams who
you are interested in hearing from
once they know that you're taking the
short position they know who you are
they don't want to talk to you how do
you get the ear of somebody who's kind
of predisposed to see you as the bad guy
well i
try first and foremost to operate in a
way that is completely unassailable
so
if if they if the company's management
was to reject me to look at me in the
wrong way
to try and do something it should you
know for the most part make them look
unreasonable and make them look guilty
um
so
even if if the management
itself may view me as their adversary
i have been to events for example where
the shareholders of the company
know who i am and hold me in some regard
so if you know the company um
companies executives
try to be hostile towards me in those
in-person events shareholders have
intervened on my behalf
because they understand that i'm not
there
to cause
a scene i'm not there to create any
drama
i'm just there to observe and i'm there
to
engage just as any other market
participant
would
um
so in general in general i i have a good
track record of being able to sit down
with management because just frankly
it's easier for them to do that because
maybe there's a small chance they can
convince me that you know everything i'm
asking about you know i'm just
completely misguided
um so far hasn't happened
but
but still they can at least try
um
but it's interesting because you often
hear other short sellers say
that they don't speak to management
because they don't want to be seduced by
the lies
i would like to tell you all that i
think that is complete bs
um because
if there's any
you know very solidly consistently you
know bs detectors in the market
they're short sellers um they're deeply
cynical it's going to be very hard for
any even the most charismatic of
management to ever um be
convincing them of of any sort of lie
um so
i would think that most of the time
other short sellers say this
because
they don't get the same opportunity uh
to meet with management because they
operate in a different way so you know
they might have a much more public
presence they might be publishing
reports they might not might be you know
frequently talking about the company on
twitter and like live tweeting meeting
with management
uh so
you know i don't i stay away from all of
that because i see the value um in
actually being able to sit down and have
those discussions uh if nothing else if
there's nothing informational it's
really about
sometimes the softer things and being
able to assess behavior in those
meetings and establish like a baseline
you know how stressed is this executive
um you know how much is he he's sweating
in these situations
uh so i hope that that through this
i'm able to just sort of normalize
having discussions you know for for
company management to sit down with
those who have critical views and
probing questions just as they would um
you know with any analyst who wants to
congratulate them on good earnings it
should be just
a sign of a healthy market
um you know
and and
the strength uh really of the business
itself
yeah i think one of the one of the
biggest examples that you know annot and
i talked about in the lead up to this
talk was you know your work on wire card
and sort of you know how you were able
to get inside the tent and figure out
what was really going on
so i think it would be great if you
could talk about that maybe a little bit
yeah so
wirecard
criticism of wirecard began the day
there was a wire card and it didn't
start with short sellers it started with
wirecard's own shareholders
um
this was a business that was focused on
processing payments in the early days
for online pornography
and that's literally all it was
and
in some ways that's literally all it
ever was if there was any legitimate
part of wirecard's business it was that
it did it processed porn uh process for
porn it processed for um you know
offshore gaming
things like this the sort of gray market
of e-commerce wirecard was there so yes
that was the legitimate piece
of wire card
but the thing with these types of
businesses businesses that are focused
on facilitating transactions in the gray
market digitally
um they're doomed to failure
so
lar by and large they never go public
because they don't want the scrutiny um
and they never get very large uh and
that's just because they are limited by
just the economics of the business model
because
the more your transact you know have
transactions that are in these sketchy
areas the more likely that a consumer
will allege fraud and if there's
potential fraud and you know the the the
bank that issued that credit card
agrees with the consumer then you're on
the hook
and then you have to you know the fees
start to add up and eventually what
happens is you get kicked off the card
networks
so
this is
in a nutshell what wirecard's business
was yet somehow wirecard managed to
become a 20 billion dollar company
it managed to send those shareholders
that
asked those probing questions
to jail
uh and
it also managed to
time and time again
completely
just brush aside
short seller allegations
and
this last round of criticism against
wirecard
it also tried to brush off um
so
let's you know
go back a few years
um
to
2017.
so at this time um in 2017 a lot of
things were happening um especially
within the payments space
um
if you don't know already wirecard
you know now people are admitting it was
basically a front for
global money laundering
um
what you see happening in 2017 is that
a lot of the business a lot of that
laundry business that was flowing
flowing through wirecard
finding a home in crypto and in digital
assets and we actually see
a lot of the the individuals that were
bringing
business to wirecard
now starting you know crypto businesses
instead so wirecard was you know
fundamentally under pressure because the
whole thing was kept alive because they
had
tremendous volume coming from that money
laundering business
so what happens next uh
germany decides wirecard is one of the
best companies in our country so we are
going to include them in the the dax um
so dax you can think of like a
the german version of a dow jones
so it's like the top you know most
solidly blue chip companies
in germany
and they were going to include
wire card
at the same time
a whistleblower who worked uh for
wirecard in asia came forward
uh with
fraud um
fake contracts
that he saw in
wirecraft asia and he then took that
information and went to the financial
times and the financial times started
publishing
on wirecard so what was wirecard's
response
fake news
financial times is criminal it's
colluding with short sellers
and what does the german securities
regulator say when uh
you know one of the best
financial news outlets decides to
you know publish all this critical work
on this business the german securities
regular regulator baffin
comes out and says
we're going to investigate the financial
times for market manipulation
so
take it a a few months later uh what
happens next
why are cars stuck after it gets in the
dax
the stock price doesn't seem to go up
anymore this is not this is a problem
and it also the stock price also seems
to go down when the financial times
publishes reports so what does the
german securities regulator decide to do
they say we're going to ban short
selling in wire cart
so
this was just an incredible moment and i
was actually at cassidy the for the
first time
within days of of this announcement
uh and it was the
first time you've ever seen this in any
developed market where a single security
that isn't systemically important have
uh you know short selling ban it was
absolutely insane
um so we knew at that point
despite our efforts to get boffin on
board with our analysis that they
weren't going to do anything
so as a short seller it's really
important for us to focus on who is
going to care
about the information that we have and
our research was focused on money
laundering
and money laundering matters to no one
more than the united states um so that
was our angle so we dug in deep we tried
to figure out everything wirecard was
doing in the us we tried to figure out
all of the actors involved who was the
kingpin of that business um and we tried
to
get as much confidence around that
information tied up neatly in a bow and
give it to authorities
so that they could
do do that the the the next steps which
would mean subpoenas um so this
eventually led to
march 2020
where the kingpin of the us business was
um arrested
and another a german
former wire card guy was also arrested
and this was again before anyone really
knew what was happening because no one
was following the us and what was
happening here um but wirecard's
co-founder um the supposed russian agent
jan marslick he was of course following
what was happening um and this this u.s
guy who was arrested was his best friend
so
in
it was the second week of march uh it
was at jan marcel's 40th birthday party
he had a complete mental breakdown he
drank two bottles of vodka was
by himself was rolling around the ground
crying
you know mumbling to himself
um you know and and two months later
wirecard of course collapsed um because
that man janmar select was gone
two billion dollars we're gone
and c'est la vie i i i had just covered
my my wire card the my last few shares
that i had short uh it was about two
weeks ago um because it was finally
delisted officially so i'm no longer in
the trade
oh
i mean that i guess that that's a phase
where the you know the book is finally
closed on the wire card trade
it i know that you you put out a paper
on your funds on your firm's website
basically explaining
you know your response to bothen's
decision sort of a
argument for your role as the short
seller and keeping the market honest
and i think i'm kind of curious what was
boffin's response to that paper were
they receptive to your argument
um
well they didn't ignore me
uh they
you know before i published the letter
of course i gave boffin a chance to
respond to me uh and sit down with me
and
you know what did they say they said no
they said no they didn't ignore my
emails they didn't ignore my letter they
read my letter but they said no um you
know i reached out to them again after
that you know i have information i have
analysis that i you know i feel you
should know about wirecard and they were
like no
not interested
i was in frankfurt speaking at a legal
conference
and i was outside of baffin's offices
i called them i said you know i'm here
i'm outside your door can we meet
and they said no
so
they
you know just like i said i had this
information that i tied up you know put
it on a silver platter tied it up and
both
had to they were not interested uh so we
had to find authorities that were
interested in that information
so you kind of have yourself in this
position where you really have to go
over their heads for somebody to start
paying attention to it
yeah and i never want to do that it's
you know
it's a it's a german company right uh
they are the domestic regulator
you know i don't like to like i said i
don't like to create drama so
i i didn't want this to happen i gave
them every chance in the world
but it wasn't even like i wasn't getting
through to them it's just that they were
just saying no they wanted nothing to do
with me
and you know perhaps it's an issue of
alignment of interest you know if it's
your country's darling company that's
driving your stock market you maybe
don't want to be the person who allows
people to put in bets against them
well yeah because germany is largely
it's an industrial manufacturing type of
economy so this was a technology company
or at least it was able to go around
parading itself as so
uh so it was within
german interest to of course promote
that even if they didn't necessarily
know the criminal extent of the
behaviors that said um you know there's
perhaps you know between the us and
germany there's a misalignment of
geopolitical interests here um because
the u.s of course is a lot more
interested in money laundering
they're a lot more interested in going
you know
against you know up against these
sanctions on russian oligarchs that is
something that is a geopolitical
interest for us also because we are the
the world's fiat currency so we
do need to worry about the integrity of
the the dollar and end of u.s financial
system so money laundering is a big deal
for us
germany
you know it's a dime a dozen how many
money laundering scandals happen there
um and i don't think this means that
you know we can
just say
germany is a money laundering haven but
it's just not a priority for them
nationally just as much as trying to
diversify their economy maybe and it's
it's interesting that you know if you
fast forward to today and we look at
what's going on in ukraine with the
crisis with russia
one of the
potential i guess penalties that has
been talked about is
limiting or cutting off access to the
swift system and so their rumblings that
russia and china are looking to create
an international payment system you know
what what does that do if suddenly you
have a section of global
economy that is cut off from
u.s control and influence that's sort of
a check and balance that's removed
well it just it's so interesting that
that we're at this moment because
olaf schultz the the new chancellor of
germany was in charge of you know
overseeing financial regulations
um
under merkel uh and that was during the
wire card schedule so he was in charge
of overseeing baffin during that whole
period and that isn't to say that he was
guilty of anything
but it is just
um a severe lack of oversight
so so i think that that's all it's all
very interesting to see how this has all
been playing out politically
um but you know can we
we already have
an economy
that exists outside of
the financial market that the us
oversees and regulates right um it's the
thing is these criminals organized crime
have found a way to make that market
bigger and more liquid and more
convenient
uh for them
through innovation
and the government you know just as it
is with with most things
is very slow on the the innovation side
and as
it's going to be a really hard game
of catching up now to all of these new
innovations in d5
you know web 3 all of these things
while
it's like these these criminals are
printing money
that's that's
effectively what it is so
rogue rogue states uh more oppressive
regimes they
might see a benefit in all you know
aligning themselves with these criminal
interests because it suits
some of their own national priorities
right so
it's going to be be difficult but i
think
we need to act sooner rather than later
and that this isn't to say that you know
we cut them out of swift i think it's
probably it's it probably more difficult
um of a of you know and not as practical
of a thing i'm you know i'm not sure how
it would work but
uh just thinking about where is the dark
money
or how is that currently you know
existing what that economy
um how do we
do a better job of
regulating it or at least integrating
um
you know our own economic system our own
financial systems in a more cohesive
sort of way
right i guess it's how do we get a
handle on these flows of payments where
as with many other things technology
seems to move a mile a minute and
government regulation can hardly keep up
with the pace of change yeah but but
human beings are also prone to failure
i'm sure everyone has
you know read about the great bitcoin
heist
you know what how did they eventually
get caught it was because they
put money onto a prepaid card
um and you know that's that's also kind
of you know what led us to wire card
um because eventually you need to be
able to use cash
and prepaid cards have just it's they're
very old school
but they're also still very convenient
but these are little things you know
prepaid cards are not a new innovation
um and ultimately
people who are
you know needing to have clean money
they they sometimes want actual cash
so if they need to use a prepaid card
for that then you know
maybe we need to start thinking about
why do we have prepaid cards in the
first place
right exactly um
so i i think as we're thinking about
situations like wirecard you know you've
got a couple different players who are
expected to sort of keep everybody
honest you've got the government you've
got the investors such as yourself who
are looking at the company and trying to
figure out what's going wrong and of
course you've got you know the the
auditors who are supposed to vet the
financial statements for accuracy i
think one question that kind of pops up
as we look at the situation is
why wouldn't the auditors have
identified these items perhaps before
short sellers would have caught on to
them you know given that they were
essentially responsible for ensuring
these were accurately presented
this is a
uh this wire card i think it is a unique
situation
it is a you know very clear example of
what we would call an overly cozy
relationship between the auditing
partners and wire and their client your
wirecard in this case
um
so
it became
uh
one when you're auditing someone for
such a long period of time
um you start asking fewer and fewer
questions or you take certain things at
face value
um so i think we have to consider you
know what is the right period of time
that an auditor should be
auditing a particular business and
balancing you know their expertise
and familiarity with the financial
statements but also you know with the
fact that they are
so closely working with the same climate
client for many years um so so that's
uh one issue
but
you know we can't just depend on one
piece one stakeholder within this
ecosystem to find everything because
auditors can get screwed over two
because when we're talking about frauds
when we're talking about criminal
businesses criminal management
sociopathic management they're gonna
you know lie and say whatever they need
to create whatever fake documentation
that they need to to defraud the
auditors as well uh so we can't forget
that piece so there needs to be multiple
checks and balances here because
you know
you know it's not as though short
sellers are the first line of defense
and fraud um you know we're basically
like one of the last lines of defense
against fraud
uh so
yeah i i can't just put all the blame on
the auditors and at the end of the day
auditors are hired by the company itself
and they're not there
to
find fraud they're there to just ensure
all the boxes are checked that
the books are balanced
um and that's that's really the the crux
of their job
what i don't think auditors maybe could
they could perhaps spend more time
um assessing some of the like softer
features and and more governance related
features uh within a business like tone
at the top uh i think it's really
important to understand the culture of
the place um because
fraud doesn't occur in a vacuum
there's usually opportunities incentives
that exist there
for someone to potentially put their
livelihood on the line to commit fraud
that will
enrich the business so
uh yeah i think there are small things
that that can be done but even still i
don't you know it'll never end with just
the auditors um i think every
piece of this um is equally important
and i i think that tone from the top
piece is really one that
does or ought to resonate heavily with
you know the people on this call who are
from the stanford business school and
other business school classes who
may well be going on to these sorts of
leadership positions at some point in
our career and will be in the position
to set that sort of a tone and you know
basically
it's that
the the trouble begins long before it
gets to deciding which numbers to adjust
or which figures to fudge it really
starts with how people think about you
know right and wrong within the culture
of the company it sounds like
yes exactly and sometimes it's just as
practical as like what can you get away
with um because not everyone is going to
have the
you know most startling uh moral compass
so with wirecard for example
they were
literally taking plastic bags full of
cash to and from wire card headquarters
right and wirecard employees everyone
this is in full you know plain sight
right uh so if if i'm some middle
manager in asia and i i hear that this
is going on then you know i i realize
that
i can be as aggressive as possible um
and i'll still have a job and i'll
actually be rewarded um by the business
oh my god it sounds like something out
of a movie when you describe it that way
like it's like a scene from wolf of wall
street i don't know
i mean this is this it's worse it's it's
even worse
so i think you know as i guess as we're
getting down to some of our final
questions here i think one other one
other item that comes up from our
audience um
within within the gamestop saga of last
year and sort of this narrative driven
narrative driven short selling and short
squeezing
melvin capital almost went under because
of their short position on gamestop and
i think there was another fund that made
money on the opposite side of that trade
going long
and i think that the question that comes
up a lot from you know retail investors
and people who are kind of watching the
market is
would there might there have been any
sort of manipulation that had been going
on you know are there bad actors perhaps
who are
you know getting involved in the midst
of all this
there are bad actors everywhere i mean
there are bad actors regardless of of
market conditions
um
and
i think just the difficulty of
generating alpha
in these markets has have probably
um forced some managers
who
previously were not overly aggressive or
you know taking
excessive leverage or
engaged in any kind of
dubious market activity you know perhaps
they've felt the pressure to just
because it's so hard to prove yourself
to your investors
or it's it's hard to keep your track
record going because once you start
making a lot of money people are going
to continually expect you to
uh
whether around gamestop there was
manipulation i mean i
it's it's beyond it's beyond my
expertise i have no idea as a portfolio
manager would i ever put myself in a
position where in a single stock
bet long or short i my business can go
under
i would never do that um but that's me
um and i'm a short seller with a
perverse
uh relationship with risk and i'm saying
this so yeah i i don't i don't i don't
understand why a pm would let themselves
let their book get to that point
but things happen you know
funds blow up people move up move move
on there is it's not necessarily
conspiracy it's this is just
it's it's the jungle you know this this
is
this is how it goes
just it's just the the nature of playing
the game so to speak
well and that's the thing this market
has been all about playing games and not
about thinking
so i i think you know as we're i think
as we're sort of getting down to the end
of our time here um
i think
i'm just kind of curious to hear a
little bit more about you know what it's
like to be family career and sort of you
know what's what is the best day what
does the best day in your life look like
and maybe what is what does the worst
day look like
yeah the the best days are
you know the ones where
that nagging question that i have that
i've been obsessing over for like a year
i'm finally able to answer it
however that may be
um and those days are only rivaled by
the days when
you know my i finally see
my thesis materializing before me you
know when a company
comes out during their earnings and
totally kitchen sinks it um and
when
authorities come out and say that they
they've made arrests of key figures that
i suspected were engaged in criminal
activity or it's when
um the ftc sends a cease and desist
order to a business uh that we believe
was preying on consumers so when when
things like that happen those are the
most satisfying those are the most
rewarding days
the worst days are days like this one
believe it or not um it's just days
where the markets are bleeding
where the markets sell off broadly um
violently um
because they make my job as a pm very
difficult because i can't rely on my
trusted toolkit
you know i can't just look at my thesis
i can't look at my information my
analysis my research
i have to
start making decisions based on things
that to me feel more speculative um so
basically how much can
how much further down can something go
um and you know how much risk am i
willing to leave on the table
so
uh every day you know i think that you
know i incrementally get better at this
and there's no better test than you know
the one the market we've been in
uh
but it's still it's it's really hard um
as you know someone who's so research
driven if if fundamental factors remain
unchanged
you know just to find why i should
change my positioning
it's very difficult
so does how does a day like that
typically unfold what's going through
your head
i i guess i do talks to cassie because i
feel like every time i've done a cassie
talk it's been a bleeding day in the
markets so yeah i just i don't try to
get too
reflexive i just take a step back focus
on my research and you know get a good
nice rest and then decide what i'm gonna
do the next day no one's gonna die
what about some of these things like
there's this new york times article that
came out recently where i think you
mentioned that
i think your printer turned on one night
and started printing out whistleblower
letters just on its own without any
input from you and it was almost like
you know somebody had hacked in and they
knew how to get at you
yeah i uh we we deal with this kind of
stuff all the time um it's like a
running joke whenever something bad
happens um you know we
will attribute it to like wire card or
some other you know
criminal interest that we might be on
the wrong side of uh but you know you
get you get used to it i i think in some
ways i've learned to embrace it because
it's probably validation that we're
we're on the right track with whatever
we're doing
um so i never it never gives me pause
uh i you know when i got into this
business of course i knew it was going
to be a dangerous business did i know
how dangerous it could get
absolutely not but
uh
one of the main learnings is that you
can never be paranoid enough um so i'm
i'm always cautious i'm always observant
um
but you know now i'm i'm in london right
this is i
there was a time when i was nervous you
know maybe i couldn't i couldn't do this
kind of work in london but you know now
i'm all in
so
i i think here you know you always
london is one of those places
parts of the city are basically owned by
russian oligarchs it's a very
interesting experience so it
i find it you know it's it's an
adrenaline rush to be in the lion's den
i mean do you feel like london is sort
of the i guess the best place to be and
to have you know a bird's eye view
across all of the all the global markets
rather than you know the u.s centric
perhaps you might get in new york
yes exactly you're you're basically
smack dab in the middle um and it's a
gateway
um right for for all of the
the money laundering activity london is
the gateway to the united states um and
i think that it's really fascinating to
to see play out because in some ways you
know how miami could be considered the
gateway um for latin america
to get to the us
london is the same for you know
all of europe um and and also asia so
it's it's a really great place to be
um
this is the birthplace of a lot of
fintech businesses um so you know i get
to see it all happen firsthand
so
i i think we've got a couple minutes
left here and i think
you know i i think what could be
interesting to talk about is
our is there anything that you're seeing
lately that perhaps you're not getting
asked about as much as you wish that you
were
about anything uh honestly
people don't really seem very concerned
whether
or not there's actually deep levels of
fraud and criminality at any business
um that's the thing you know very
broadly no one wants to get in the weeds
no one wants the expert view everyone
wants like the one-liner
um they want
very superficial analysis
very you know one-dimensional analysis
no one really wants um
to hear
about you know all the work that that
goes into to
to the businesses that we're researching
um i think mostly because they don't
care um and and people will only care
after sentiment in the market shifts um
and we haven't gone to that point yet
i mean do you think that that's going to
change in
a year's time perhaps if things get
tougher or are we is this just how
how things are set to be just is it just
human nature
yeah i mean cycles will play out as they
play out um and you know some people
will get lucky and calling it the right
way you know i think we all know how how
this ends um i just i you know i have no
idea when when that happens but does
that it doesn't really matter
um for for the strategy because we're
just always short you know we're always
mostly 100
short um the markets
you know through the various
companies that we're betting against so
whether there's
mass calamity
a market apocalypse whatever it may be
we are just
here being patient continuing to do the
old-school old-fashioned kind of work
that we've always been doing
it's true
there's true uh scuttlebutt diligence
and digging in
exactly i want to thank you thank you so
much for joining us fami and for
everybody who has been on the line with
us
and hope everyone has a great rest of
their day
[Music]
you